what is it like reliving a lot of these
experiences as they play out on tv
we don't watch it no we haven't for a
while just because it's like we lived it
and we are so open and honest that it's
like
we're not gonna relive all this stuff
again i have to congratulate you
so exciting you're currently expecting
how are you feeling
i'm feeling really good now um 17 weeks
as of today i feel really good i'm due
like september 2nd
would you show us a little glimpse of
the beautiful bump
you definitely tend to grow more
there you are oh you look so beautiful
thanks
how is this pregnancy comparing to yours
in the past um you know i feel like a
lot of my pregnancies are very similar
i definitely have for the most part
pretty easy pregnancies
um so this one so far has been just
as normal as it possibly could be which
is good of course i follow you on
instagram i saw you revealed you're
having another girl
which is so so so exciting and you also
teased
that you and tyler have already picked
out a name and i'm wondering if you
might share it with us
no we're not sharing with anybody until
she's born i can tell you that it starts
with a z
and that's all i'm sure people can tell
just from our other two kids like we
like different names
we like different unique like
not so heard of names do you think after
this baby that the
baltierra family is complete or do you
guys still want to try to expand
no i mean as of now i'm like this will
be our last child that means i've
carried four children biologically
like you know i feel like it'll feel
complete and my body is cut off
it's done whatever we are given we are
meant to have
and if that's a house full of girls poor
tyler but
that's what we're meant to have i guess
of course today we are celebrating
your amazing pregnancy news but um you
know i just want to offer you
a piece of my heart i was so touched
when you revealed last year that you had
suffered
a pregnancy loss why did you decide to
share that publicly
um i think it's important to share it
public publicly like you know i
had one recently too just before this
baby
um so i've had two so far i just think
it's important because
a lot of women don't talk about it they
feel like they need to be in the dark
about it and not speak about their
emotions or their feelings
um and the sad
part of reality is that it is a lot more
common than women think or even than men
think you know
and it takes a toll on a woman whenever
you get a positive pregnancy test and
you've been trying to have a baby like
you automat when you see those two lines
you automatically start getting excited
and thinking about the future
and um just thinking what is this child
gonna be
like and then when you are to lose a
child like it is a very hard it's hard
on
the mom it's hard on the dad like i
think it's just
we need to bring awareness to things
that
women go through and how hard that they
can be um
so yeah that's why i'm super open about
everything that i struggle with whether
it's mental health
miscarriage like i feel like the more
open you are it helps people not feel
alone
so of course and i can't tell you how
much i commend you for being such an
open book because
you probably don't even realize how many
millions of people across the world
watch you watch your story and feel like
you mention
just a little less alone i help people
not feel alone but in return
also it helps me not feel alone so i
think it works both ways
what have you learned about yourself by
either going through this
this horrible experience or even by by
putting it out into the world
um i think i just realized really like
how
how strong of a person i am and that the
mental health work that i really have
done and focused on in the past that
people got to witness
has really worked like the work that i
put into it has really worked
um because this time with this
miscarriage it was sad of course
and i felt my feelings and emotions but
it didn't it didn't
overcome me like the first one did it
didn't send me spiraling i was able to
feel my feelings to cry if i was sad but
it just didn't overcome me which i could
tell was a huge difference
why the hell are you yelling at me i
think it's just important for parents to
have your own purpose
moving on to teen mom og what can we
expect throughout the remainder of the
season you watch like the journey going
through the miscarriage and things like
that and then just
you know besides that sad part there was
a lot of joy in our season this year
which is so good
it's just a relief you know we've had a
few rough seasons
do you and tyler sit down and do you
re-watch it every week and
like what is it like reliving a lot of
these experiences as they play out on tv
um you know for you know we've done this
show for so long that now we don't we
don't watch it no
we haven't for a while just because it's
like we lived it
and we are so open and honest that it's
like
we're not gonna relive all this stuff
again um was it just too painful
i think some things are painful
obviously there's a lot of joy too but
i think also like when you start to
constantly watch yourself all the time
then you will want to start tweaking
things about yourself
also um like oh maybe i shouldn't have
shared that or
dang i really shouldn't have done this
or said that and it's like no
i would rather just be 100 authentic
because that's how people connect
and i'm just gonna live my life and go
through what i go through
and whatever they share i guess they
share
we got pretty lucky though didn't we i
think so honey
you got to marry your best friend i know
how cool is that not a lot of people get
to do that
no i love you
do you ever go online and see how much
positive praise there is for not only
you for being such a strong
woman and an incredible mother but also
for tyler for being
a through and through family man and a
real
pillar of support for you through thick
and thin oh no i definitely do
see that for sure i think it's great
because because that's who he is
you know he cares about his children he
cares about his family
and you know he he always wants to be
supportive for all of us
we do the parenting stuff very well
we're good at like
you know splitting it down the middle
you know and helping whenever
you see the other person needing it or
asking for it like
we make we make a really good team we
have done lots of therapy as a couple
um i mean years of it um
and you learn a lot through that about
communication and asking for
what you need but also i think that you
know it's also important to like take
time
with just one another especially when
you have children because
you can really get lost into the
parenting day-to-day life because let's
face it your kids
come first you have to really be like
whoa i need to take a moment
and just spend quality time with my
partner
and enjoy each other's company like
that's super important
of course we love following along with
nova and veda as they're growing up how
are your girls doing
um they're doing really really great
veda is
so she's just getting really big she's
using more words
um but she's also very sassy but she's
also very like cuddly and loving too
and nova is very outgoing and funny
um and so you know i'm just
i'm blessed that she loves school she
enjoys going to school and she asked me
like 10 times a day like how are you
feeling
how's the baby doing um you know when
after we first told her she came up to
me the one day and she's like mom
you're only allowed to have one cup of
coffee a day and i was like
where did she hear that i don't like
where did you get this from she's like
too much coffee is not good for the baby
mom and i was like are you my little
doctor now
like you know she's always randomly
coming up and kissing my belly
and all that kind of stuff
[Music]
caitlyn we've really enjoyed being a
part of your journey
over the last 10 plus years how long do
you see yourself
being a part of this franchise and how
will you know when it's time to walk
away
um tyler and i have had this discussion
multiple times
um we say as long as it's doing good in
the world or as long as it's still being
educational and
infor informative in some type of way
i will continue to do it now if it
started
being scripted or them throwing things
in the mix to cause drama
or anything like that then i would
completely walk away
but as long as that's still doing good
for people
i will continue to do it you know you're
on a show called teen mom og
but if we break it down you are a loving
wife
you are a really proud mom and
you're nearly 30 years old so how do you
feel about
being part of this teen mom universe do
you still think there's a
stigma attached to that title i think
there will always be a stigma to the
title of teen mom
or 16 and pregnant or young and pregnant
i know it is funny i've joked with like
you know the higher up execs
execs where i'm like can't we just
change the name like we're not
teams anymore what's the answer you know
they they're just like well that's how
people know us though like you know once
you have a fan
base that would be like as in lady gaga
changing her name
if you think back on the last 10 plus
years is there a moment that you
really love and stands out as your
favorite and is there a moment that is
uh too hard to relive you maybe wish
cameras weren't there for
i think honestly the hardest things to
film about was when i was struggling
with my mental health and like leaving
my family and watching how it affected
nova
and my husband and my family like that
was super hard
and also i think something that when i
am older
and carly is in her 20s or 30s
um i'm blessed to be able to have
a copy of my 16 and pregnant episode
that i can show her
i don't even have to say too much we can
watch it and then i can answer questions
that she has
because it was so 100 real
and i still haven't been able to watch
my 16 year pregnant i can't do it
have you ever seen it so i watched it
the first time it ever aired in 2009
um and then there was one time tyler and
i were probably
19 almost 20 and we were at our trailer
that we owned back in the day and we
were folding clothes and for some reason
it popped on
and we ended up not even folding clothes
for like five minutes and just sobbing
and so i was like we need to shut this
off and ever since then no i haven't
watched it it's too hard to watch
i'm just going to be 100 open and honest
with her and with veda and nova
like i'm not going to hide anything if
you ask me any question about it i'm
going to be 100 real about it
well you're an incredible mother and an
incredible woman my last question to you
you know you brought up that
it's challenging to relive those moments
where
you know your mental health was really
at the the forefront of the conversation
um how are you doing today um i'm doing
really well
i feel good my mental health is really
great
um family's great we're all healthy and
happy
so as long as we all stay happy and
healthy and
then i'm good with that